no sé si es la mejor decisión valentina
pero definitivamente refleja el estado
de deterioro de la alternativa política
a la larga hegemonía de benjamin
netanyahu este ha sido seguramente el
intento más importante que se hizo en la
última década de tomar el poder por
parte de la coalición de 8 partidos que
ha sufrido los últimos cinco años en
tres ocasiones diferentes para poder
consolidar de alguna manera la
posibilidad de pensar en un israel
diferente del planteado por netanyahu y
ya lo has visto todo el partido likud ha
sido muy paciente en vaticinar que este
es el fin de algo que empezó sin
perspectivas lo que vamos a ver en breve
en octubre de noviembre es si
efectivamente la larga hegemonía
política de uno de los líderes
históricos y por supuesto la visión
geopolítica y la visión de estado que
trae consigo una tal 'yahoo se
consolidan y vuelven al parlamento más
allá de las acusaciones de corrupción y
de la alianza de todos contra el que se
llevó a cabo unos años atrás bueno
además de inestabilidad división que
demuestra que haya unas quintas
elecciones en algo más de tres años
y no demuestra que por primera vez en su
historia israel está en una profunda
crisis institucional política
ciertamente la composición social ha
cambiado muchísimo hay una presencia
como bien apuntaba la nota de fuerzas
políticas de minorías étnicas dentro de
israel una israel dentro de la cual han
sido muy cuidadosos a lo largo del
tiempo en que los judíos tengan el
control político ahora esa alianza ha
demostrado no estar todavía maduras las
posibilidades de pensar una israel
plurinacional un israel que es capaz de
pensarse desde diferentes facciones en
un diálogo en una conversación frente al
tradicional mundo digámoslo así de la
derecha hebrea no es pensable ha
demostrado que no ha cuajado todavía no
está lista israel parece paz pero con
esto que usted está diciendo y
analizando el panorama actual se puede
esperar que un próximo gobierno pueda
mantener la estabilidad
el costo de la estabilidad es lo que
preocupa porque es que tampoco es el
país homogéneo que estaban acostumbrados
a gobernar netanyahu y los líderes
tradicionales hebreos este es un país
donde ya han cobrado voz diversidad es
otro tipo de identidades no
necesariamente relacionadas a la línea
de ascendencia directa de los judíos y
entonces esto va a complicar mucho más
el próximo gobierno sea que sea incluso
netanyahu guardar el orden mantener la
estabilidad va a tener un costo social
muy alto aparte del costo político